let's see if you can solve this
fractions test the answer Choice closest
to one-half is four over seven five over
nine six over eleven seven over thirteen
or nine over sixteen
there are many ways you could work it
out but here's how I would do it we
first put equivalent fractions to
one-half for each denominator so we have
3.5 over 7 4.5 over 9 5.5 over 11 6.5
over thirteen and eight over sixteen so
each fraction is slightly larger than
one-half the first four are point five
over the respective denominators larger
than one half and the last is one over
sixteen
so clearly from the first four options
the smallest increase over one half is
point five over thirteen so we know that
a B and C are not the correct answer
now point five over thirteen is equal to
1 over 26 which is smaller than one over
sixteen so answer Choice D is actually
the closest to one-half